I don't want to spend a lot of time on
this but megan kelly is leaving leaving
fox news for NBC the background is that
megyn kelly spoke out with regard to the
roger ailes sexual assault scandal she
did so later than others but she did do
it some people criticized her for that
others understood that given the sort of
fear of retaliation that can often exist
in power dynamics that there's many
reasons logical reasons why she may not
have spoken out there well she is going
to be leaving fox news reportedly she
will be going to end NBC she'll be
hosting a daily daytime show as well as
a Sunday newsmagazine program what's the
future of fox news you first have Fox
News tied up in terms of how much drama
there will be between Trump and
Republican politicians if Trump and
Republicans are buddy buddy the Fox News
narrative will be pretty clear we like
this administration if there's tension
between Republicans and Trump as we've
already started to see and I talked
about earlier today will Fox News have
to pick a side will fox news go in a
different direction altogether I really
don't know Fox News has some real issues
Pat and one other issue they have is
that Greta Van Susteren recently left
box news megyn kelly is leaving that
will leave no female hosts in Fox's
prime time scheduling up maybe that's
good I mean maybe the Fox News audience
doesn't care about having female hosts
but it is yet another interesting
element given that there was a major
sexual harassment scandal involving
Roger Ailes and a dozen women at fox
news when it seems like Donald Trump was
going to lose the election there was
talk about him creating Trump TV yeah
Roger Ailes and some of the Trump
loyalists at Fox like Sean Hannity now
that he's won the election I don't know
if there's really much of a place on
that Network for more of an anti-trump
voice so I think she's making the right
move here I think she's making the right
move and I think that a sign at Fox News
will be if megyn kelly is replaced with
a very clearly pro Trump host that is a
very different signal than if you do
something like uh you know when Brit
Hume was brought in temporarily to
replace Greta Van Susteren who is an
ideological extremist no doubt but he's
not as much of a committed trumpets the
other interesting thing Rachel is what
happens at NBC I mean I'm guessing that
when you think
MSNBC you think oh that liberal
editorially Rachel Maddow etc uh what
happens if you bring in megyn kelly at
NBC do is the reaction NBC is going
right wing or is the reaction well maybe
megan kelly really isn't a right winger
she was playing one on fox news and
maybe this is gonna bring some kind of
balance at NBC i don't know i think it's
how it's going to play out will be in
large part due to her followers and the
people who have supported her on fox and
if they have a more uh political
ideology that's to the right are they
going to follow her there or are they
going to stay at fox news so i think
that those people are going to have a
large part in it I'm actually going to
start watching some of these channels oh
look i don't know but last time i
watched box for five minutes i thought
it was a parody i turn it on i thought
oh this is like when an SNL skit would
be if you were to parody fox news
particularly Fox and Friends I mean it
just it's a bizarre program I get enough
digests and sort of like highlights of
what's happening on each channel each
day through newsletters that I can
basically completely avoid tuning into
any of these channels which I think has
been really good for my emotional health
yeah definitely i actually thought that
once too and i turned on the television
and fox and friends and i said oh SNL is
on in the morning you kind of can't tell
the difference yeah it's it's very very
strange what's going on